[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti è un onore per me
tra l'altro essere la prima a parlare
quindi un onore e una responsabilità e
ultimamente di responsabilità me ne sono
capitate abbastanza come diceva carolina
con quella chiamata inizia un percorso
un percorso che viene generato da un
evento molto negativo per alcuni
addirittura tragico ma che poi per una
strana e fantastica coincidenza di cose
ed incontri si alimenta invece che di
rabbia e rassegnazione con
determinazione forza e coraggio
inizia tutto con quella chiamata in cui
sia io ma anche migliaia di
risparmiatori vengono avvertiti che i
loro risparmi
non ci sono più di questa storia ne
avrete sentito tutti parlare ovviamente
tv giornali
trasmissioni televisive però a volte un
fiume in piena di informazioni fa
perdere la bussola e allora oggi sono
qua per raccontarvi la storia da
un'altra prospettiva dalla prospettiva
di chi questa storia l'ha vissuta sulla
propria pelle
diciamo che dopo il primo e momento
iniziale di smarrimento con gli incontri
opportuni e nasce un gruppo facebook
nasce tutto da lì si chiamava vittime
del salva banche lo trovo già con questo
nome mi scrivo anch'io
e succede quella cosa di cui vi dicevo
prima che invece che solo la
rassegnazione
cerchiamo di mettere in gioco altre
forze e ci organizziamo
anzi siamo anche un po autoritari perché
cacciamo fuori dal gruppo tutti coloro
che si sfogano e basta si lamentano e
dicono che sono disperati perché la
disperazione deve generare sempre
qualcosa altrimenti è solo e
semplicemente di istruzione facciamo un
passo indietro
prima di allora prima dell'azzeramento
delle quattro banche perché la mia
associazione rappresenta i risparmiatori
delle prime quattro banche è andata e
risoluzione
nessuna banca era mai fallita e poco
sapevamo dei bilanci di questi istituti
men che meno conoscevamo la nuova
direttiva europea in
argomento di salvataggi bancari per
questo ovviamente la nave è affondata
con tutti i risparmiatori perché il
governo aveva deciso di anticipare
addirittura un questo provvedimento
europeo del bail in che prevede non più
salvataggi esterni con l'aiuto dello
stato non salvataggi interni utilizzando
quindi il patrimonio investito fino ai
conti correnti dei risparmiatori
decidiamo di organizzarsi dicevamo
nomino un coordinatore per ogni zona gli
istituti sono quattro e sono tutti del
centro italia però rappresentano
distanze geografiche importanti dopo due
settimane riesco organizzare la prima
manifestazione in piazza siamo a roma ci
conosciamo casalinghe impiegati piccoli
imprenditori pensionati gente lontana
anni luce dalle alchimie della finanza
dalle acrobazie azionarie
e pensare che ci hanno chiamato
speculatori capiamo che qualcosa di
profondamente ingiusto c'era appena
capitato ai giornali ancora non parlano
di noi cerchiamo a questo punto di
organizzarci con uffici stampa che poi
anche il mio lavoro
facciamo un vero e proprio ufficio
stampa cerchiamo di informare i
giornalisti di quello che era successo
all'inizio sono informati solo i
giornali economici ovviamente i quali
sapevano bene di questa direttiva
europea del bail in certo però non
sapevano e non potevano immaginare a
quali
investitori a quali risparmiatori
fossero stati destinati è qui il
problema è qui che parte la truffa dopo
la prima manifestazione cerchiamo di
darci un calendario poi un evento
inaspettato il primo pensionato che si
suicida era un risparmiatore di banca
etruria si svegliano tutti le
televisioni inizia non seguirci
diventiamo il contenitore principale di
tutte le trasmissioni soprattutto quelle
del mattino ma anche quelle di
approfondimento della sera
l'ansia e la rabbia e la disperazione di
chi aveva perso tutto perché
personalmente io sono ritengo di essere
una privilegiata in questo perché ho
perso anche io mia mamma diversi soldi
ho perso 100 mila euro
ma non era tutto il capitale che avevo
alcune persone hanno perso veramente
tutto e tutti i propri risparmi e
provate a immaginare cosa significa aver
vissuto un'intera esistenza metter da
parte per un figlio per un parente per
la vecchiaia e svegliarsi una mattina e
sapere che non c'è più niente
guardate che in queste titoli che sono
stati acquistati non c'era scritto
obbligazione subordinata non c'era
scritto il rischio non c'era scritto
niente
si tratta di una grande truffa iniziata
dai manager di queste banche e avvallata
poi purtroppo anche da quelli che
dovevano tutelare dal governo dalla
consob e da banca d'italia lo
scaricabarile che stiamo vivendo in
questi giorni è solo qualcosa che noi
avevamo annunciato due anni e mezzo fa
quando ancora la gente non sapeva renzi
dopo l'ex premier dopo ovviamente
che siamo riusciti a cavalcare tutte le
trasmissioni televisive siamo riusciti a
uscire nei giornali e corre ai ripari
dice che senza il suo decreto sarebbe
scoppiato l'armageddon e che sarebbero
andate a casa i dipendenti delle banche
in realtà poi è successo lo stesso
in realtà si è voluto utilizzare questi
risparmiatori come cavie da laboratorio
ma noi ce ne accorgiamo
se non fossimo scesi in piazza se non ci
fossimo organizzati se non fossimo
andati a parlare con i vertici apicali
del nostro azzeramento banca d'italia e
consob il ft di il fondo interbancario
il ministro padoan
ecco noi siamo stati a colloquio con
tutti questi rappresentanti
istituzionali e abbiamo capito una cosa
cosa che non si può capire neanche
tramite un giornale perché magari è un
giornale di parte magari un giornale che
non dice veramente le cose come sono
andati e abbiamo capito semplicemente
che questo decreto era stato fatto con
superficialità che questo decreto era
profondamente sbagliato perché poi
creerà va un effetto a catena che stiamo
vivendo
la gente ha disinvestito dalle banche
per paura
ovviamente di essere azzerata come noi e
ha iniziato questa lunga crisi che
tuttora stiamo vivendo e che non è solo
una crisi economica mi spiego cosa è
successo non vedo il timer perché sono
abbagliato dalla luce ma spero di averne
ancora il tempo è quello che è successo
e questo dal 2013 le banche hanno
iniziato ad avere dei grossi problemi
per la mala gestione di questi di questo
cda di questi amministratori allora è
successo che praticamente hanno dato
l'ordine in qualche maniera di vendere
queste obbligazioni a pubblico granulare
a seguito delle nostre denunce sono
state fatte delle ispezioni all'interno
di questi istituti ed è stata trovata
una missiva soprattutto a banca etruria
dove praticamente i dirigenti
obbligavano perché se ti arriva ad un
superiore è un obbligo a vendere questo
tipo di obbligazioni che ricapitalizza
vano in qualche maniera la banca perché
gli investitori istituzionali ovviamente
se ne erano dati a gambe legate
elevate a pubblico retail anche a voi
c'eravate è stata clienti e se
fidava te ovviamente del bancario di
fiducia quando ci siamo resi conto di
questo abbiamo avuto la consapevolezza
questa una parola fondamentale la
consapevolezza di quello che era
successo e dalla consapevolezza è
partita l'adeguata comunicazione
sostenuta anche a quel punto dai
giornali economici non solo italiani ma
anche esteri perché siamo stati al new
times siamo stati alla finanziata in
siamo stati tutti i giornalisti per
spiegare quello che è successo e molti
giornalisti esteri si meravigliavano
perché almeno in alcune nazioni
era impensabile che un risparmiatore
comune come eravamo noi che un
pensionato potesse avere in mano dei
prodotti così rischiosi danno in italia
un problema che riguarda molte banche
diciamoci la verità solo che queste
banche hanno avuto la sfortuna di avere
gli amministratori sbagliati
cosa insegna questa storia francamente
dopo due anni me lo chiedo anch'io
quale è stato il risultato di una
battaglia che ci ha tolto tempo ma mi ha
tolto tempo denaro tempo libero perché
io in 2 anni e mezzo ho fatto un po il
tour di tutte queste banche da ferrara
dalle marche cercando di capire cercando
di dare veramente la giusta
comunicazione e mi rispondo in questa
maniera il risultato che abbiamo
ottenuto non è solo il rimborso che pure
abbiamo ottenuto per gli obbligazionisti
soprattutto delle fasce più deboli e
dell'arbitrato per quelli che avevano un
reddito superiore non è solo stato
questo senza la nostra protesta comunque
non ci sarebbe stato neanche questo
e i suicidi sono stati molti di più di
quelli che sono stati annunciati noi
siamo in contatto con tutte le famiglie
il risultato non è un salto questo è
stato quello di capire che grazie alla
consapevolezza non rimanendo nella
superficie riusciamo a vedere un mondo
diverso e ad avere la giusta motivazione
che non ci spinge solamente nella
rassegnazione
quando ognuno di noi sa di essere nel
giusto ha veramente la forza e la
volontà di combattere e questo è il
piccolo miracolo
che abbiamo noi abbiamo combattuto
contro forze assolutamente più grandi
eppure in qualche maniera abbiamo
influito anche su di loro
[Applauso]
[Musica]